thinking thinking welcome back to the on
Julian podcast dink dink dink dink dink
dink dink I hope mumbles hand the entire
time no no I'm putting him we're gonna
hold hands I'm on the floor if you know
I think we're gonna hold hands you
doesn't like it no he doesn't like it he
doesn't like his hands being touched
yeah he puts up with it cuz he loves you
he doesn't like it he loves me mm-hm
this episode is brought to you by me
undies welcome back everybody
me and uses three times softer than
cotton the best underwear you can buy
delivered straight to your door free
shipping and cozy up with their new
robes for men and women treat your feet
with their soft new slippers and of
course their underwear go to meet undies
comm slash Jenna Jillian get 15% off
your first pair and free shipping check
out their collection also guys if you're
gonna build a website do it with
Squarespace Squarespace is the most
amazing website building platform if
it's a hobby a small business whatever
it is use Squarespace it is website
building made easy you can make a really
beautiful website without knowing
literally anything about building a
website they take all the guesswork out
of it go to squarespace.com slash
annejulien and you can save 10% off your
first purchase of a website or domain
click the link below to get started
thank you sponge Thank You sponsors
that's that nuts not gonna happen but
we're holding hands that he's kissing me
god you find a way to top your weirdness
and every single time with the way you
kissing during the podcast don't be
holding hands and kissing you for this
is not the Jenna just licked by marbles
for an hour podcast I don't know maybe
it is our marbles are you replacing me
my out are you in
come this way young man
I'm calm young man young son all right
we're holding hands again he's kissing
me all right we're ready
don't put the mic in his face what are
you upset that's what you hear all day
every day Kermit's is worse Carmy just
loud er they're both worse they're both
they're both worse Kermit's been so
annoying lately the way he wakes me up
he's like he's like an aggressive licker
but runs like back and forth right in
front of my face and steps on my head
and then licks my forehead one time and
then walks all over me no don't need
that don't need that you know what this
is my safe space from that this is your
safe space this is where I escape that
to do other things like talk about
recipes and podcast things so don't talk
about him licking when he's not looking
because that literally like brings me
into them into the experience of it
happening when it's not actually happens
just like walks up to my forehead lick
stomps all over my face and head walks
back lick stomps all over my face hey
that's my coffee wait why don't you
bring your own deal with it no I'm not
gonna deal with it yeah you are cuz I
just take a sip I was you I'm gonna spit
it up you're gonna deal with it
sorry it's like okay full disclosure
we're both pretty tired today so I think
that we're a little bit loopy right now
sometime not so no just get hit with the
tired z' is that wrong did I say that
wrong yeah a little tired no way you're
tired because I for no reason started
singing what's that song time of my life
yeah you started like without hesitation
beatboxing I was like now and the time
of my life and Julie starts going oh
[ __ ] we've hired me out here being
[ __ ] loopy tired oh no what have we
done also occurred today Jenna wouldn't
stop watching tic TOCs and I was trying
to get her attention about the podcast
yeah and I said as a half joke you're
being a bad business partner and she
goes and like jaw drops at me like I
I can't believe you just called me that
and I look at her while she's her jaws
drop she's like and she goes it turns
into a yawn and I was like hello you
kidding me right I just witnessed the
jaw drop - yawn transition you hit me
with the jaw drop it was like like how
could you say but I literally it
couldn't have come at a better time -
because of what I said
[Music]
don't call me that you beat we're out
here today though you know also shots
out Lizzie for the All Blacks All Blacks
uni I stole it from your bag that's mine
oh it's mine now we can share it but
you're gonna give it back to me that's
my shirt
Lizzie gave me like some really pretty
like bobby pins and I wore one last
night and he was like taking him out on
the bag and he's like oh so big a nice
tie clip and I'm like give me that
that's not yours you can't just take my
bobby pins and turn them into a tie clip
somebody tell me that I'm wrong okay
seriously a bobby pin the type that
doesn't have the curve because some of
them are fancy can yeah some of them
aren't curved some of them are
completely flat and there was a smaller
one and I was like this is literally a
tie clip tell me I'm wrong but it's not
tell me I'm wrong anything's the tie
clip if you clip it under your tie
that's what I'm saying
but it wasn't yours anything's produce
have you stick it in the fridge Julie
[Laughter]
that is how it works no yes it is yes it
is
when did you start saying that like the
first time you said that was so funny
you were like anything something if it's
like that
yeah anything's food if you eat it or
something I don't know stupid like that
I don't know I don't remember things
that I say anything's a knife if you cut
with it yeah anything is a competition
if you win it mm-hmm anything is my high
school English teacher if you cut it out
I'm just kidding I never cussed out a
teacher I was just watching take talks
for so long yeah oh that one tick tock
was so good the wine the one like I
would love to make a podcast where I
just sit and watch tic TOCs because I
love but again like okay is that worse
logistically well no you could record
your screen and we could I wouldn't even
be a part of the podcast
it would just be Jenna and the screen is
just a tick-tock
I love it like uncut we should do that
next time I'm I'm out of town okay well
won't record in advance he'll just
record without me I was just like I was
saying we thought make a funny video
absolutely crying you just sit and watch
tic TOCs like like this one they can't
even see oh my can't see you're holding
up there so basically dump slime down
the back like a show the one of the girl
telling her mom to sing this one this is
the funniest thing ever I laughed for
like 10 minutes in that that one was
really good and then I laughed at this
one for like 10 minutes you can't see it
this is awful no I hated stupid but I
loved it this one made me laugh
knocks over glass of red wine like
everywhere okay this is actually it's
actually your turn off this went to a
wine tasting with the girls and this is
why you don't go wine tasting with the
girls you can make I think a video would
be good were you recording the screen so
it's like visible and audible I just
like they make me laugh it's like it
reminds me of when I used to just sit
and watch lines for hours it's exactly
it's exactly and nobody wants to do it
with me except Brett sometimes what do
you mean I was just doing with you don't
say usually like Brett would come over
on the weekend and I would just show him
all of my vine likes from the week and
we would have a good like hour where we
could just sit there and die laughing
why don't you public your legs maybe I
will maybe I won't people been asking
for you to drop that like you know
anyway um today I've even watching tic
TOCs and loafing I'm a loaf full of
marbles Arlo don't Julie I'm just
watching take dice on the couch and I
started laughing so hard over like this
as I smacked him like right on his
button he jumped up in the air I'm like
he's so scared today I know he's he's
like why are mommy and daddy's Energy's
all [ __ ] up and why are they like
moving the way that they are I'm so
sorry Bobby sorry there we also tried to
cut his nails and he he didn't like it
no we gotta take him in yes yeah he's uh
he's literally like you know he packed
such a punch like if you have a
chihuahua or maybe like small dogs in
general public you look at him and
you're like I got this like you put him
on his back and you're like trying to
look at his feet you know and then he
scared the living [ __ ] out of me
screaming at me like I've never I like
you're not expecting such a loud attack
it was so just just gnarly like it felt
like I was actually scared for a second
like scared the [ __ ] out of me and I
look and I'm like Jesus Christ he like
knows how to [ __ ] it is so strong his
neck is strong Mikey you can't ever
really hold him down
he's such a beat burst energy so like
this like you're ready to get close to
his nail to try and cut it or something
is so he pulls it in like as hard as he
can like one at a time so that by the
time really trying to actually cut a
yeah its first you never get in that's
what it is it's like it's very like
methodically timed yeah bursts of
yelling and movement and it makes him
impervious to bigger predators or your
owners trying to cut your nails my
marbles well we're gonna do some trivia
because we I don't know if he's played
on the pot we play on the probably a
long time ago it's one of my favorite
games played a game called wits & wagers
and we're not gonna play the whole game
because it doesn't really make sense for
the podcast we're just gonna fine now
well we're just gonna take the trivia
portion and we're just gonna do trivia
but the way wits & wagers works is a
really fun game we always play it with
my family we play with your family it's
like a tradition every time they come we
play it and so we're not gonna get
through all these but we'll get through
a good amount really fun if you come
from a family of smart little
know-it-alls which I think everyone has
in their family yeah but the way the
game works is you all have betting chips
and you have a little card with a dry
erase marker and the question will pop
up like how many people a year go
skydiving right and everyone at the
table has to write down their closest
estimate of what the answer is and then
you put the answers down in like in
numerical order or you know in lower
lowest to bet on and then your link is
right you can bet on other people's
answers
so you all you have your own guess which
you get a bonus chip for if you get it
right but then you can bet on other
people's which is a really good but it's
you basically you win chips and whoever
wins the most chips wins or whatever so
it's like they're meant to be like
trivia questions that no one's gonna
know the answer to but that's why it's
fun if you want to play along so the way
yeah I mean some of them yeah some
people might know but they're meant to
be they're meant to be very obscure yeah
and the way we're gonna play is just
guessing audibly because we're
Podcast and a lot of you guys just
listen to the podcast and even if you're
watching you can enjoy it you can do it
that way don't do that okay we're gonna
do number one what percentage of
American adults make their own bed every
day mm-hmm well I know that people that
have been in the military tend to make
their bed so I don't know what's that
percent they definitely do how
interesting I don't even thought of that
and then people that like comfy beds and
I'm gonna say 40 percent forty percent
yeah make their own beds every day yeah
I'm gonna go ahead and say 20 ah even
less yeah hmm all right here we go
27 whoa I'm not part of that 27 percent
I was for a little while and then we
started sleeping with just a sheet
because it was so hot during the summer
and then it's like what are you gonna
make a sheet no sleep there and now we
have a weighted blanket so making the
beds like a workout cuz I think it's
[ __ ] heavy but it's wonderful it is
heavy I really like it it's funny cause
like when peach gets up in the middle of
the night I can feel her like trying to
push it up yeah it's actually easier to
trap Kermit now so in the mornings when
Kermit wakes up and he does his cry
alarm toss at like 7:00 a.m. on days
that I just really don't have it in me
to like wake up right then in there I'll
grab him and I'll just really tightly
like cuddle him so he can't escape
because he wants to escape and cry but
what I'll do is I'll cuddle him and
they'll wrap him in the heavy blanket
and he's all he's done oh yeah I think
it does a little bit he's a nervous boy
how many calories where you won that one
yeah I didn't how many calories does
gum-chewing burn per hour 3-3 calories
per hour
oh yeah no that's not right 30 80 wait
you can't just read the answer now you
already know it well I already guessed
mine
yes talk about the logic 30 and I said
80 what's the logic give us give us a
breakdown I thought I saw like a
statistic or something somewhere I know
that celery is like the same amount of
calories burned as as it takes to eat
the celery you know it's like it's a
negative calorie it's like a food that
doesn't exist by the time you eat it
you've already burned the calories yes
so it still goes out the other end so it
does exist okay you know it does exist
ask your but you said 30 yeah I mean I
feel like that's kind of low but yeah 30
11 I was closer than using both times 75
an hour oh that's nasty I wasn't kissing
someone for a [ __ ] hour
that's disgusting that is disgusting I
don't know I feel like when I was 18 I
thought that that was pretty great okay
imagine an alien life-form has a peek
into humanity and looks at a couple of
people kissing for an hour and just
kissing and the alien life-form is not
capable of love and so they're looking
at these two creatures just sucking face
for one hour the most just how would
that you that doesn't even make sense
it's the most insane how many calories
you think the dogs burn by licking each
other one because they're licking like
substance off and they're gaining
carriers gross so gross okay kissing
would burn 75 folding clothes 150 have
you seen me fold clothes I do it way
faster than that I would burn like 300
minimum an hour folding clothes that's
such like everyone does that differently
yeah I think it's I do a back flip
between each t-shirt that I fold so it'd
do way more calories okay good for you
have you learned the army fold it's
really nice for shirts it saves a lot of
space in suitcases no it's like the army
roll whatever it's called Mason I mean I
have seen it on tape no I did it in
Hawaii yeah when we were in vacation did
you watch me baby I was folding my
clothes I do I've also seen it on dick
duck but first they saw me do it tick
tock no I I was first tick tock
what's the maze what's the major league
record for most total runs in a baseball
game most total runs holing my both
teams both teams add it up in one game
41 it's a high scoring game 41 I'm gonna
say 52 oh wait so both teams have like
in the 20s or it's just a blowout 50 to
nothing 49 Oh sigh one guess what the
score was
what 26 23 oh boy who's pitching y'all
defense
suck both y'all all y'all did they just
put the pitching machine on the mound
for both teams it's somebody's dad to
come because Lily's 26 23 with only
three home runs many singles okay how
many publishers rejected the first Harry
Potter manuscript before it was accepted
oh I don't know maybe seven like a lot
probably
how many publishers I'm sure someone
actually knows the answer to that for
real because people love Harry Potter
zero they accepted it on the first one
that's my guess this is a trick question
Wow twelve Wow the Harry Potter series
has sold over five hundred million
copies so ups that's what it says just
gotta keep on trying in the first you
don't succeed try many more times than
than you JK Rowling you miss 100% of the
shots you don't take
said Wayne Gretzky as he took a shot of
tequila at work and got fired in minutes
how long can an emperor penguin stay
underwater mm probably a long time right
well it says minute so it's probably
minimum one minute it's not ours well
it's also not seconds but they're Birds
you want a piece of me
they're Birds it's not legal like a
whale see a penguins not like a whale
get back clear
[Laughter]
you know I'm really goofy move don't say
something like that okay I would say I
don't know it's something impressive but
like not too impressive because he's a
bird five minutes that's a long time
five minutes is a long time for people
yeah but it may be when they spend a lot
of time in water they spend a lot of
time in water
yeah I'd say five minutes five minutes
I'm gonna say 20 minutes they're birds
they have to breathe air yeah they're
like birdie really not like whales quite
like well quite like birds either I mean
I don't how many penguins you look up
into the sky and see flying bird is kind
of a weird classification for that eyes
for a sec no they can't I could fly for
a sec - if I jump in flat my own yeah
it's because I jumped mm-hmm I don't
know it's kind of flying tell us the
answer I say what did I say 20 minutes
I'm gonna amend my guest 12 minutes you
know yeah 22 minutes 22 minutes so they
are like whales yeah they even have a
blowhole this emperor penguins have been
recorded fishing 1800 feet okay that's
wild
how do their ears not just implode so we
don't really have yours they have like
holes Wow right wonderful
I don't know either having a penguins
head when we watch it's like this
when we watch that we watch that series
on the treasure-hunters the guy whose
dad remember what was Cooper's treasure
no no that's the other one
billion dollar wreck billion dollar
wreck that's the one I'm talk the guy
whose dad work with the iPad iPad yeah I
need a really toxic relationship with
his son yeah so and his way the depth of
there is wait for the depth of that
wreck was what do you remember like
ballpark no because 1,800 feet seems
like yeah they were at what to have to
like change to helium when they were
nitrogen Serena no is helium they didn't
feed him nitrogen you would die no is
nitrogen poisoning
oh no no so I thought they gave him
helium at a certain they did yeah it
changes their vote yeah yeah so um they
basically they're going down to like
look for treasure on this old shipwreck
that they found and they have this this
diver rappel into the water and when
they reach a certain depth they have to
switch it from oxygen to helium because
something about the pressure at that at
that depth it would kill you if you're
at air and the helium makes it so that
you can still breathe that depth or
whatever but like it's such an insane
process and one of the divers almost
dies because they actually like they
didn't get him up in time and he like no
he's almost too fast the too fast
forever and they then they have they to
put him in this chamber where he like
sits for days and days and days to like
react Allah made his body but he's like
throwing up it's like insane it's like
really crazy because it makes your blood
like poison pretty much yeah to think
that a penguin can just casually [ __ ]
goats pretty almost 2,000 feet
underwater it's pretty awesome
[ __ ] hell okay what is the record for
most knives thrown dude I like this most
knives thrown around a human target in
one minute I don't even know what that
means
in one minute around a human target well
like if someone's standing like this and
they're just trying to make an outline
yeah in one minute
113 they're using both hands okay 113
almost literally means that they're
throwing two knives per second hell yeah
LeBron James throwing
41 okay 144 yeah get rekt dude that's
over two knives a second yeah and the
description just says haha what the hell
we should look up a video not now
someday 144 knives I want to get into
that sport that sounds like terrifying
um I bet that guy was really peeing his
pants
the guys sitting up yeah I wouldn't
volunteer to do that yeah look he had me
undies on though so even though he was
being as pensive is still comfortable
because they're three times softer than
cotton and have really cool prints and
colors and designs and styles for your
liking especially around the holidays
when you're looking for gifts for people
me Andy's is there for you to get those
gifts because what's a better gift than
really wonderful soft comfortable
underwear that might even have a festive
print on it
well when these are rubber ones these
are robes or slippers they have so many
things now I me and he says so many
things so get yourself some me Andy's
guys every holiday season you can cozy
up with me Andy's and now you can get
their wonderful robes which I have yet
to try I can't wait to get it in the
mail because that's what me Eddie's does
they mail the underwear and the garments
to you so you don't have to go to the
store and shop for underwear because who
the hell wants to do that okay you can
cuddle up with your boo with your dog
they have you covered literally they're
gonna cover you because their underwear
and other garments like the bralette
that Jenna wears all the time sizes
extra small to four XL three times often
the cotton is like being three times
softer than those cute little
marshmallows at the top of your hot
cocoa oh it feels so holiday in here now
oh you didn't have to go there I did it
- it sounds so good go to me undies
dot-com slash Jenna and Julian get 15%
off your first pair and a hundred
percent satisfaction guarantee while
they ship it for free
check it out wonderful wonderful stuff
also guys
Squarespace listen okay you need to make
a website whether it's for a school
project or your new side business or
your photos that you wanted to put
somewhere or maybe it was a promposal
you just want to build a website for it
Squarespace has got you covered you can
build the website exactly how you want
it with ever without ever needing to
actually know how to code on a website
they make it so easy they have design
templates that not only look beautiful
but they're easy to use and customized
to make it look exactly how you envision
they have 24 hour a day 7 day a week
customer support so that anytime you
have questions about maybe a problem
you're running into or a feature you
like to use and you don't quite know how
they're there for you they're there for
you it's amazing all the time customers
report they have live webinars that you
can tune into and watch to learn new
things about how to maximize what
Squarespace has to offer so check it out
and once you build a website with
Squarespace we love to see them so tweet
your website's at us that you build a
Squarespace because I think it's awesome
to have someone tweet that I mean I
click a link and I'm like damn you just
[ __ ] built a website and I love to it
you know you learn a little bit about
someone's hobby or their work or
whatever it is so check it out ok think
it dream it do it with Squarespace go to
squarespace.com slash Jenna Julianne to
save 10% of your first purchase of a
website or domain or you just go to
Squarespace comm and check out a free
trial and see how you like it
thank you sponsors ok this is a good
question Marples resting his face on my
finger don't surprise him
mumble put your head back it was cute
you're like a little baby board ok how
many munchkins were cast in The Wizard
of Oz mmm I feel like I know the actual
answer to that I've heard it but I just
don't remember it like 30 or 40 The
Wizard of Oz or maybe even 70 there's a
lot I was confusing it with really what
are the the Willy Wonka Oompa Loompas
mm-hmm so in the Munchkins where where
are they in that in that movie they run
in are they in are they at Oz yeah or in
you know when they meet Glinda the Good
Witch or whatever yeah that's like the
scene I mean I like haven't watched that
movie in ages but
it's look around in there her my dumb I
am watching alright you guess 20 no oh
where'd you get 30 30 and then I said 70
so I don't know which one is my attorney
no 30 I'm gonna say 12 124 yeah as a lot
each munchkin made $50 per week Toto
made a hundred and $25 per week [ __ ]
that dude imagine being on set and
looking over and seeing a dog make
almost triple what you're making for
just being a dog dogs can't use money
[ __ ] so annoying you're running around
you're doing take after take like your
home in
how many people attended history's
largest free rock concert history's
largest free rock concert why does it
say nice tree why don't this just say
the largest free rock concert oh yeah
like what country do you think that's in
then Europe somewhere in Europe yeah
it's got to be hmm I'm bad at estimating
numbers of where do they do large groups
isn't there like one insane music
festival in Europe somewhere there's
like a really famous one what is that
what I'm thinking of in Amsterdam maybe
am I crazy I don't know somewhere I feel
like it would have had to be in Europe
does it include like everyone there over
like a weekend period or a little that
one probably then maybe I don't know
200,000 people hmm maybe like Germany
mmm 200,000 I'm gonna say 500,000 okay
3.5 million oh we're idiots
Rod Stewart 93 New Year's Eve Copacabana
beach at the go but go but Cabana
where is Copacabana is Havana the girl I
know that song where music and faster
we're always they fell in love
Siri where is Copacabana beach I found
what did you know that did I know what
public cabanas in Brazil no that's right
I don't know what are you asking me
what's the question cut okay
what percentage of Americans think
they're smarter than the average
American oh my god a hundred perseus
that's a weird question okay how many
people think America at all yeah percent
seventy five percent I'm gonna I'm gonna
think that they're smarter than the
average American I'm gonna say eighty
yeah
fifty-five only four percent think
they're less intelligent than the
average American you know what something
about that four percent makes me think
that they're more intelligent than the
probably for answering that question
like that I honestly believe that
according to Disney how old is the
oldest of the eleven official Disney
Princesses this is all for you wait wait
wait what reading again how old is the
oldest of the eleven Disney Princesses
Oh Snow White
wait what do you mean how old or which
one's the oldest what's the old is the
oldest oh that's no wait how old it's
not it's only its oldest movie I'm
confused are they asking the the
question of which of the princesses is
the oldest in the film yes come here bud
okay so I don't even know who the eleven
princesses are Snow White jasmine
I've no idea Ariel wait why are you just
looking all right no okay so so yeah the
character which character which
character in their respective worlds are
the oldest so Ariel's like sixteen okay
Jasmine I don't know how old jasmine is
but she lives with her dad but that's
like a cultural thing yeah she could be
any age Snow White I didn't think was
meant to be like super old is Rapunzel
considered one I don't know or
Cinderella caldas see no way I say no
Anna I feel like Cinderella is a little
older mm-hmm but I still think that
she's
to be like 18 or something mm-hmm I feel
like we're splitting hairs it's gonna be
like no you are but Jasmin was was 20
years old so it's interesting to just
hear your breakdown of it I'm serious
because I know okay so they're all
relatively young yeah because then they
get scooped up by princes real fast
before they've even had a chance you
live their lives and find out what their
own interests are okay you want to get
back to the question I guess what goes
to nur Ella how old um I don't maybe 19
or 20 because she gets like full blender
Ella 19 hell yeah she got like ballgown
married you know it's the same she
didn't have like a little wedding who's
Tiana Tiana Snow White's youngest at 14
see that's [ __ ] sick like that man is
kissing a 14 year old girl he might be
young till is he a man man he's a man
yeah that's not [ __ ] cool dude damn
you [ __ ] nailed that one
thank you me good job don't congrats I'm
talking to my mic the Appalachian Trail
runs from Georgia to Maine in miles how
long is it Georgia to me Georgia to
Maine what that's like the top of the
country to the bottom of the country
yeah I guess cuz you only ever think of
the country's from east to west or west
to east and that's what it's like how
many miles
it's like 3,000 3,000 miles and so from
the south to the north
well it's like a sort of a rectangular
shape of a country so if you can imagine
it's 300 no cuz I would make it a oh
you're right No mmm 1,500 seems high I
think I'm gonna go with like 1,100 I'll
go with 1,500 2189 so it's Maine which
is at the tippy top which is sort of an
outlier staying as if you're putting
like a rectangle square it's outside of
that square and then George is at the
very bottom 21 points are the very
bottom but okay well it's pretty low but
it's also coming a little west too
because Maine is up there and then you
go down and then a little more West for
a Georgia mm-hmm I'm a topographer I won
the average thru-hike takes about five
point five months with the record at 46
days someone hiked that in 46 days I
have a cousin that I'm like related to
that not like first cousin or even
second cuz I don't think that that ran
across the United States and his wife
biked beside him what before he went
through 11 pairs of sneakers oh my god
yeah how people that are much better
than me honestly I disagree thank you
they're all like really great I think
they did it to raise money for the Red
Cross really yeah they're just like
really good when did they do yeah many
years ago and then I'm pretty sure how
many pairs of shoes eleven so he packed
12 shoes I you know I don't know the
logistics of what he did if he had to
like stop and get new shoes that he
bought them would he carry a doctor on
his back to like heal him and yeah and
he carried a doctor on his neck idea him
with the stims get him a little quarters
in the shot keep it going
okay on average how many pounds of poop
does the male African elephant produce
per day marble they're big poops yeah
they're big those things are huge her
day so they probably anymore let's
measure in permits he's like 10 pounds
so they probably do like he's like one
part of it like maybe three Kermit's is
one like a 30 pound poop
yeah but they probably do that multiple
times per day so I'd say 120 pounds oh
my god I'm gonna say 89 pounds okay 235
pounds of poop that's good that's a lot
of [ __ ] damn that's a lot of worms zoos
often sell their abundance of elephant
manure too eager local gardeners Oh
interesting that's cool yeah that's
really cool I gotta go grab some [ __ ]
I'll be right back all right cool what
are you gonna get [ __ ]
since their 1917 debut how many
different types of Girl Scout cookies
have been sold different types so you
have the Thin Mints you have the no
that's your shortbread cookies
shortbread cookies so ones with the
chess pieces on you have the ones that
look like the coconut ones yeah those
are like the spiky ones yeah then you
have the awesome blossoms meal reason
I'm a raisin chocolate chip - they're on
chocolate chip I don't know you have to
imagine they've probably gone through a
couple flavors that no longer exist
totally maybe 3030 yeah I was a 20-19
1990 1956 why am i bad at this game but
when you're playing with some wagers
what makes it really fun is that if
Julian guess is something that's like
not good but someone else has a guess
that he thinks might be right god oh my
god you just bet on that guess so Julian
ends up winning this game a lot your
brother wins more this he never actually
answers the question correct yeah but
that's that's the trick mm-hmm throw
them off with the wrong answer and then
just jump on board the right answer Thin
Mints selling 50 million per year boxes
this accounts for 25% of all sales Thin
Mints are the number one cookie yeah has
to be with that now they're really good
yeah how many questions does the average
four-year-old that's per day oh oh my
god so many I'm sure which four-year-old
we talking about oh man me as a
four-year-old I is a sky-blue why that's
the why right why it's like right when
you you answer a question they're like
what's coffee Oh coffee's a drink why
does it have cat what is caffeine why
why do you drink that does it taste good
day why 801 I would say 70 390 oh my god
300 questions that's exhausting it's so
exhausting politicians and press
conferences are asked fewer questions
per hour than parents Wow
that seems like a weird it's really
funny your boy okay that's really funny
how many of San Francisco's iconic cable
cars run on a normal day hmm
how many actual of the cars this is a
question for someone who grew up in the
bad I don't know 120 mmm there's not
like a ton of them but they go all day
like 39 okay
twenty-seven man the cable cars go nine
miles an hour and serve about ten
million riders per year that's actually
27 that makes it even cooler that
there's only 27 running in Sam it's
really cool yeah have you been on one
mm-hmm they're pretty cool right yeah
how many cups of water can in an adult
Pelican hold in its pouch which is I
think the lower be fun okay pelicans are
big birds yeah those things are big how
many companies all like stretched out
yeah it's like over a gallon for sure
like a cup they could probably hold a
good like 30 cups I want to say I'm
gonna say 60 cups I'm gonna say 31 okay
48 in 48 cups marbles 48 cups
after fishing they must dump 24 pounds
of water before they can fly oh my god
so they go onto the surface of the water
they scoop it up and they're too heavy
to actually flies drop 24 pounds of
water and sift through the water to get
the fish that's how I eat mac and cheese
mm-hmm on TVs Wheel of Fortune how many
pegs are on the outside of the wheel
that's good there's a big wheel I want
to say one per minute like a clock I
want to say sixteen I want to say
there's like you know little slices of
whatever you have to think of how many
pegs are on each slice it's probably fun
and then how many slices there are yeah
so like maybe five per slice or less
maybe four three I think there's five
per slice in 12 sizes 66:12 maybe one
there's like a looser turn there's like
I'll [ __ ] win a cabin oh it's
probably like get a car no I think at 60
do you think there's 60 total pegs I
think that there's a hundred and fifty
total pegs 72 mm weird number that is
weird
the wheel has 24 wedges yep and weighs
2,400 pounds that's a thick wheel
how many coils does an official metal
slinky have hmm 100
I've added estimating numbers of things
really m69
yeah 98 yeah it was originally designed
as the spring I'll be careful
for sensitive nautical insurance maybe
really sensitive
what is sensitive nautical instrument
what is that I don't know okay a
nautical instrument that just is having
a lot of feelings when it's sensitive in
days how long does it take from take
mercury to make a full trip around the
Sun is mercury closer to the time it
would take less yeah so like 50 days 75
days I wanna say like 20 days no I was
like 70 20 okay 88 good guess don't
offer Neptune has the longest journey or
on the Sun at about a hundred and
sixty-five Earth years
that means poor little Neptune that
means a year on Neptune there's a
hundred sixty-five years mm-hmm
Wow no one ever turns one everyone's
dead okay how many instruments did
Prince play on his debut album mm
probably played drums guitar what else
did he play keyboard keyboard probably
the triangle I don't know well
what did what did he get into in his
first novel based on the way this
questions were at least we think there's
a lot it's like this this synth are they
considering that and probably for this
question or a flute I don't know did he
put without a recorder I'm receiving
songs I'll say 627 among them were the
fuzz bass poly Moog finger cymbals and
water drum oh yeah Wow hell yeah I like
that I like that what percentage of a
Twinkie is air how I don't know how did
someone calculate that probably put it
in a science machine pretty awesome um
24 I didn't guess um percentage Twinkie
is air 4068 what the remaining 32% is
made up of 34 ingredients there's 34
ingredients in a Twinkie probably jeez
feel like it shouldn't be that
complicated no I shouldn't okay well do
one more the u.s. space shuttle program
ran from 1977 to 2011
how many shuttle launches were there I
have no idea so it's almost 40 years
it's like 36 years but there were some
years in there that they were doing
multiple launches No
or am i dumb I don't know I feel dumb 30
198 okay
135 yeah about eight astronauts were
accepted each year from 15,000
applicants yeah out of 15,000 damn
well I did awful as I expected I love
with some wagers so fun and the full
game is really fun
not spawns not spawns but it's genuinely
one of those games that like for when
families around whether it's for the
holidays or whatever it's just a really
fun like family game because you all
everyone has a chance everyone can play
everyone can bet and he's meant to know
the answer yeah and like it doesn't it
doesn't make you feel like you can't win
a game because you don't know trivia
because you can always bet on the
answers and maybe you're betting an
intuition in that sense is just better
than other people's it's a nice fun
gambling aspect yeah if you want to
gamble with family it's getting darker
like 1:00 p.m. these days so everything
feels weird and we're tired but
hopefully you guys are having a good
start to your Monday yeah and I
genuinely hope you guys are you know
you're thriving and you're well and
you're excited for the months to come
holidays are approaching yeah good time
of year you get your temperament lattes
in here I haven't had any peppermint
latte we should get something we should
get some peppermint lattes I gotta do it
I got to start doing some festive food
for my for my cooking videos I wanna do
some latkes maybe you can have yes you
can matzo ball soup please that's a big
matzo ball hanging out that was a sign
thought it was a good Seinfeld joke
Julie I'm a bigger Seinfeld fan than
Jenna no that's not true
i watch all of them he really likes
Seinfeld all of them Oh
welcome to the dark side mmm it's really
great here okay anyway thank you guys
for listening and tuning in you guys in
a society Jerry if you don't want to be
part of society you get in your car and
move to the east side
oh man it's such a good show okay we'll
see you guys next week have a wonderful
week and we love you bye
[Music]